[Music]
where to invest billions of dollars is
the literal definition of a rich
person's problem the Byron Trot and
Michael Dell think they have a solution
Trot is a former Goldman Sachs
investment banker Dell is the technology
billionaire entrepreneur each has their
own successful investment firms BDT
partners and MSD Capital that traffic in
billions of dollars and in October the
pair decided to join forces to create a
single player that caters to the global
Elite a transaction that demonstrates
how crucial Tycoon families and private
Capital have become to High Finance BB
is a so-called Merchant Bank Trot works
with billionaire tycoons such as Warren
Buffett and Europe's riemanns to help
them invest their fortunes arrange
high-powered introductions and otherwise
assist them with making sure their
generational wealth endures
MSD once just the asset management arm
of the Dell family is now a full-fledged
private Capital manager that with
external funds does corporate buyouts as
well as credit and real estate investing
chief executive is Greg lemkal another
prominent alumnus of Goldman Sachs
together BDT and MSD hope to create a
virtuous circle where the rich and
Powerful can get One-Stop shopping for
their financial needs the combined firm
will manage around 50 billion dollars
according to Credit Suisse the balance
of global wealth at the end of 2021 was
roughly 450 trillion dollars nearly half
of that figure was controlled by the top
one percent of households at the same
time the baby boom generation is set to
transfer something like 70 trillion
dollars to their errors which could
explain why private Capital firms now
see Elite families and individuals as
important to their growth as pensions
and Sovereign wealth funds
foreign